foreign
I would like to discuss about meditation
but first of all I'd like to ask you a
very simple question
can you see my hand
yes raise your hand
okay can you hear me
yes
great
that is the meditation
so finish
my tattoo is finished
um of course I'm just kidding
but in a way that is true why what do
you call the essence of meditation is
awareness
and what is awareness knows what you're
thinking feeling doing seeing hearing
that's all
so actually meditation is very easy
but many people found difficult
why their true misunderstanding about
meditation
so the first is many people think
meditation means think of nothing
stop thinking
concentration
I'm meditating keep quiet
so the more when you try to stop
thinking what happened you will think
more so we will do some more experiment
okay now please don't think about pizza
no pizza
no pizza
what happened
did you think about pizza or No Yes
raise your hand
I know
so
actually
we don't need to stop thinking
we just need to connect with awareness
and another misunderstanding about
meditation is what we call blazing out
looking for peace come Joy should last
the more you fall relax
then peace come Joy relax and run away
so
let me show you my own experience when I
was young I had panic attacks although I
was born in the right middle of the
Himalayan Mountain the area The Village
wonderful but Panic followed me as like
shadow
and I have so much fear for strangers I
cannot go out and meet people
and a lot of storms in the Himalaya
Mountain thunderstorm snow storm these
storms die me crazy
and when I was nine years old I asked my
father to teach me meditation luckily he
was a great meditation teacher
and the first thing what he said is
don't try to fight with the Panic don't
try to get rid of panic
and actually he said you don't have to
why awareness is like sky in the
mountain
and the Panic is like storm in the
mountain like cloud
and no matter how strong storm is it
doesn't change the nature of sky
so sky is always present pure calm
similarly our fundamental quality of
Mind awareness is always
present pure come but the problem is we
don't know how to connect with awareness
what we see only thought emotion that's
all so he said there are three steps of
practice to connect with awareness the
first one we have to use an object
support to connect with awareness so
this is one of my first meditation
technique uh what I learned from my
father
so you can join and you can relax your
muscles in your body if you cannot relax
also okay allowed
and close your eyes
and please listen to sound
[Music]
and when you hear the sound
through ear and mind together
[Music]
that is the meditation
and let panic come and go
let Pisa come and go
and maybe
to Visa three Pizza ten pizzas
as long as if you remember the sound you
can have pizza
[Music]
[Music]
okay how was it
did you hear the sound
yes raise your hand
great that is the meditation very easy
just here that's all you don't have to
do anything
so a penny comes let penny come and go
don't care just listen to sound monkey
mind comes let it come and go just
listen to sound
so I did that
but I have big problem the problem is
lazy
I'm I'm lazy boy I love the idea of
meditation but I don't like the practice
of meditation
so on and off like that for five years
when I was 13 years old
in India there's traditional three-year
ritual going to start I thought I should
join this because good for my laziness
and I joined
the first month wonderful not lazy
second month lazy come back
now what happened my lazy and my Panic
they too become good friends
the the life in the ritual become
disaster
and I thought I should leave but I feel
embarrassed to live because I told all
my childhood friend that I can do the
retreat you know I don't want to lose my
face but if I stay
almost three years to God that I thought
it was what should I do
in the end
I decided to learn how to live with the
panic
so now we have this second step what we
call actually we can meditate everywhere
anytime with anything
so you can meditate with a panic
how to do that just like listen to sound
when you listen to sound sound becomes
support for your meditation now you can
watch panic
if you see the Panic great what do we
call when you see the river you're out
of river
when you see the mountain you're out of
Mountain
so now awareness become more than panic
more than depression stress monkey mind
whatever let them come let them go so
this is the first benefit and second
benefit what we call there's a wisdom
comes
so when you look at the panic
pan is not solid Stone anymore Panic
becomes pieces sensation here
frightening image voice background
belief
and if you take one of these away you
cannot find Panic so what I call Panic
become like shaving foam look like piece
of rock but inside full of bubbles
then three what I call this is
acceptance like self-kind
self-love self-compassion you let penny
come and go
that's the really acceptance isn't it
so three in one
awareness love and compassion wisdom
sometimes what I call by one you get
true free
big deal right
and all this because of panic
so now Panic become your teacher your
best friend
so I did this practice and in the end me
and my Panic become very good friend and
a few weeks later Panic is gone I miss
my friend
and I finished my YouTube my YouTube
went very well and after that I have
been eager to share this wonderful
technique to the world so I taught
meditation many places wrote few bookses
become bestseller and then students and
become a bit of your monasteries then
what happened
kind of new ego emerge with me I thought
oh I have to watch out this song
then I decided to do something very
special what do you call wandering
Retreat meaning you left everything
behind go on the street with nothing so
I decided to do that in 2011. I left my
Monastery my student my wonderful cozy
bed
everything and go on the street with
only few thousand Indian rupees
and that finished within a few weeks
that have the Bigfoot
and I got food poisoning
vomiting diarrhea
I'm alone on the street now I'm going to
die
then I thought what should I do so now
we have the third step what we call open
awareness meditation
awareness be with itself Sky be with
itself now no need to have support
just be awareness itself so I did this
that practice
then what happened
my body become dictating I cannot see I
cannot hear
but my mind becomes so present
Beyond free
and I was in that state for a few hours
luckily I didn't die I come back so when
I come back the street become like my
home when I look at the tree tree become
like Tree of Love
and wind blows to my face become joyful
experience
and the rest of my ritude went very well
I learned a lot from my retreat so I'd
like to share this Urban awareness
meditation but it's a it is very
difficult to explain
but I want to do something drama
and this is I what I learned from my
father so what what we call this Mala is
the crazy monkey mind
and the urban awareness meditation means
you don't have to do anything just be
that's all and you don't need to
meditate the sense of presence being
but not loss
be free
be present thank you very much
[Applause]